this video is brought to you by raycon
hey wisecrack michael here today we're
going over a topic of concern to both
big
tech and big shrek what do i have to do
to get a little play message
yes privacy the answer to shrek's
question is a little
well complicated in our day and age do
we uninstall tick tock
sorry just had to wash my hands before
getting in
send a strongly worded dm to mark
zuckerberg become a juggalo to foil
facial recognition
privacy is all over the news
specifically the many ways it's being
trampled on
so exactly how angry should you be if
the chinese or american governments get
a copy of your sick [ __ ] tick tock we
take for granted that this thing called
privacy is a universal good that we
should share lots of think pieces about
but what exactly is
privacy in the first place where did the
idea come from and why does it raise
such powerful emotions and perhaps most
importantly
why should we care about the state of
privacy today
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on the philosophy of privacy
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
raycon
raycon earbuds are comfortable wireless
earbuds that are the solution for your
podcast or music
listening needs i prefer these over
other earbuds mostly because i hate the
hard shells that fall out of your ears
so easily
raycon earbuds also have different size
gel tips so you will always have a
comfortable fit
they come in a wide variety of colors so
you can choose the pair that matches
your style
raycon earbuds start at about half the
price of other premium wireless earbuds
and the audio is comparable to the brand
you might know their latest model the
everyday e25 is one of the best yet with
six hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a compact design
that gives you a nice noise isolating
fit raycon has a 45 day free return
policy so why not check it out for
yourself
click the link in the description or go
to buyreacon.com
wisecrack and you can get 15 percent off
your order
that's by raycon.com wisecrack
now back to the show the concept of
privacy as we know it now likely has its
roots in a much more basic concept
namely property the notion that certain
things belong to certain people or
certain groups and not to others
[Music]
philosophical discussions around
ownership are some of the oldest texts
we have and they lay out the separation
between an individual and the group to
which that individual belongs
and without that divide talking about
privacy is kind of pointless the most
well-known of these treatments comes
from aristotle who posited a division
between what we call
the polis or the public sphere and the
oikos or private sphere
a healthy protein classicist douglas
mcdowell points out that oikos could
have one of
several different meanings depending on
the context in a very literal sense
it can mean an individual's house but it
can also mean
all of the household goods that marie
kondo wants you to trash
i.e property in under certain
circumstances family which
i don't know do they spark joy in other
words
the greek oikos consisted of all those
things which could be said to belong to
the male head of the household the
property itself
the commemorative platoches oh and also
the women children and slaves that lived
on said property
these things therefore did not belong to
the polis the public
of course many people didn't own land
making this
not a fun time the very culturally
specific distinction between the
household and the public sphere
is a big part of the foundational
thinking that enables us to say for
instance that
data about our online behavior is ours
and that it is therefore a violation of
our rights to collect it without our
express consent
we can see how by fast forwarding from
ancient greece to colonial america
there this concept of private ownership
was also a big part of the reason why in
between teeth coins at the blacksmith
shop the founding fathers worked up such
a collective head of steam over british
intrusion into their affairs
as scholar daniel j solov explains
revolutionary americans had a very
specific grievance with the colonial
authorities
the founders detested the use of general
warrants and writs of assistance
that is you could have your house
searched and you're seized without any
basis in evidence and it was
not uncommon for the authorities to grab
the personal papers of dissidents and
authors
underlying the founder's anger was the
belief that there is such a thing as
personal
stuff to begin with in other words they
were willing to endure the pain in the
ass that was musket warfare one
two three fire
in large part to create a division
between what the government does and
does not have the right to inspect on
demand
key american figures were even wary of
surveillance by their own government
so much so that they took to writing
their post-revolutionary letters in code
this included folks like george
washington thomas jefferson and
alexander hamilton
their orneriness would lead to the third
fourth and fifth amendment
these prohibited the forced quartering
of soldiers in a home without the
owner's consent to establish the
requirement of probable cause for
searching and seizing your stuff
and establish the basics of a fair trial
respectively these amendments further
refine the concept of privacy with
regard to individuals and their
relationship to a liberal democratic
government in an american context but it
wasn't until 1890 that the modern idea
of privacy as a
legal concept was fully articulated that
year attorney samuel warren and eventual
supreme court justice lewis brandeis
published the right to privacy in the
harvard law review
it brought immediate and widespread
attention to the issue of people poking
their noses in other people's business
those two girls behind you and
publishing their findings in the
tabloids this was a popular concern in a
time when increasing population size and
rapid urbanization
brought many people into closer contact
than ever with their neighbors and as a
result
their domestic dramas in the article
warren and brandeis argued that the
common law conception of property
protections ought to cover not just
physical property but intangible
property as well
like your sorted netflix watch history
or your idea for the next great workout
yeah sure eight minute abs yeah the uh
exercise video
yeah well this is gonna blow that right
out of the water listen to this
seven minute abs
the way they saw it the law wasn't
keeping up with recent technological
developments or the businesses that
profited off them specifically
newspapers the 19th century equivalent
of tmz
as they put it gossip is no longer the
resource of the idol and of the vicious
but has become a trade which is pursued
with industry as well as a frontery
they noted that this new trade profited
off of the details of sexual relations
which can only be procured by intrusion
upon the domestic circle
broadly speaking privacy was then as it
is now
primarily about protecting your nudes in
more precise terms legal scholar dorothy
glancy claims that for warren and
brandeis the right to privacy was the
right of each individual to protect his
or her psychological integrity by
exercising control over information
which both reflected
and affected that individual's
personality in this way
these two sephia tone men expanded the
concept of the private yet again to
include not only the property in an
individual's possession
and that which is restricted from
government surveillance but also what
goes on inside one's head and
anything that might impact that such as
potentially damaging gossip
or in today's day and age your tinder
message history more recently in his
1966 study of surveillance technology
law professor allen f weston pointed out
that laws surrounding privacy depend on
context specifically whether you're
talking about the privacy of your
average citizen versus the privacy of
the government
in science privacy and freedom westin
explains that different political
systems treat privacy differently
and that norms of privacy are dictated
in large part by culture and tradition
as he put it certain privacy patterns
are functional necessities for
particular kinds of political regimes
the modern totalitarian state relies to
varying degrees
on secrecy for the regime in full
surveillance and disclosure for all
other groups
in other words the totalitarianism seen
in the soviet union in nazi germany
required privacy for government paired
with a forced lack of privacy for
citizens by contrast
at least in theory the structure of a
liberal democracy demands transparency
for the government coupled with privacy
protections for individual citizens
this statement seems perfectly obvious
until you realize that even within
liberal democracies we've never
actually reached a universal agreement
about who ought to have what kinds of
privacy and for what reasons
philosophers scholars legal analysts and
others with a vested interest have
continually argued about whether privacy
is a good or bad thing to begin with in
his overview of the history of privacy
and publicness
scholar slavko slickall points out that
private relations may also be heavily
authoritarian violent and even brutal
protection of privacy may also have
negative effects under the veil of
privacy abuses of power including
domination exploitation
violence tyranny and censorship as well
as unlawful and unethical activities in
families corporations and organizations
can be kept away from public monitoring
and righteous sanctions
to simplify privacy is great when it
means keeping our browsing habits away
from the nsa but
not so great when it's used as a
justification for hiding child abuse in
the church violence in the home and so
on
even aristotle the very thinker who
helped define the private and public
spheres
claimed that we must not regard as
citizen as belonging just to himself
we must rather regard every citizen as
belonging to the state
for all his talk of private ownership in
other words aristotle believed that the
private realm extended only so
far and that an individual ultimately
existed as part of and to serve a larger
whole
later challenges to the notion of
privacy as an unambiguous good
came from not only utilitarian
philosopher and preserved corpse jeremy
bentham who called privacy one of the
most
mischievously efficient instruments of
despotism but also
feminist thinkers such as carol hanish
who first coined the phrase
the personal is political panish and
others challenge the idea that there is
a distinction between the public realm
of tweeting hot takes and the private
realm of arguing with your partner about
what movie to watch next
they argue that the relationship between
husband and wife or mother and children
are inextricably tied up with the
politics of a broader society
to put it another way if a society
doesn't value women's agency that same
idea bleeds into the private home when a
husband refuses to let his wife help
decide what to watch on netflix the
inverse is also true if
men refuse to let women make the hard
decisions at home like whether to
rewatch firefly vs battlestar galactica
they're probably less likely to trust
women to vote or hold offices
according to this strain of thought
denying the connections between public
and private life allowed outright abuse
and oppression to go unchecked as long
as they took place within the home
beyond the reach of public scrutiny
of course this would seemingly make a
slam dunk argument for
you get no privacy on your phone because
as lawmakers try to chip away at things
like encryption
they'll inevitably point to someone
doing something bad with all that
privacy as a reason to take away yours
in spite of these complications privacy
still has its many defenders in her
article what privacy is for
law professor julie cohen argues that
privacy is vital for the development of
individual identity or as she calls it
critical subjectivity as she puts it
subjectivity is a function of the
interplay between emergent selfhood and
social shaping
privacy enables situated subjects to
navigate within pre-existing cultural
and social matrices
creating spaces for the play and the
work of self-making according to cohen
our subjectivity that is our sense of
individual selfhood as defined both by
what's going on inside our heads and
outside of them a la warren and brandeis
requires privacy to fully develop
in order for us to form our own opinions
values etc we require a buffer zone
between
what we're thinking and doing and what
the outside world can see
at least some of the time this space
between us and everything else creates a
safe area within which we can try out
new expressions of cellphone and make
mistakes that is we can do so without
fear of being mocked by the
entire internet for thinking that a
fedora would really complete our
aesthetic
or being really really into twilight
fanfic
here we circle back to weston and the
question of why privacy is so
damn important in the first place you'll
recall that according to weston's theory
different kinds of societies need
different relationships to privacy in
order to exist
the liberal democracy we strive for for
instance requires a great deal of
privacy for its individual citizens
marrying this with cohen's understanding
of the importance of privacy we could
argue that democracies have to be made
up of fully realized individuals if they
are to function correctly in other words
when we lose our privacy we gradually
lose the ability to fully develop as
humans outside of the public eye
and that's bad for a system of
government dependent on the will of the
people
and thanks to warren and brandeis we
have some idea about how to maintain
that crucial space for individual
development
funny then that as a society we're
giving away our privacy like
candy corn on halloween but seriously
for a group that's thrown such a
massive fit about privacy invasion and
data collection over the last few years
we seem to have very little problem
handing over our deepest secrets to
anybody offering a fun freemium game
and generally mashing that accept button
whenever we come across
a terms and conditions page fine you
don't want to be part of this then just
sign right here
no you didn't read it this says we don't
ever have to let you out and then we can
do whatever we want
but maybe that's not quite fair after
all we're not just throwing our personal
information away for nothing when we
permit a government or corporation to
invade our privacy by handing over
access to our data
we generally believe we are getting
something of value in return
use of a social network for instance as
westin points out the need to socialize
is a powerful one and setting our
privacy as the price of entry can make
it seem cheap by comparison he claims
that
each individual is continually engaged
in a personal adjustment process
in which he balances the desire for
privacy with the desire for disclosure
and communication of himself to others
in light of the environmental conditions
and social norms set by the society in
which he lives
french philosopher and mirror
impersonator michel foucault even went
so far as to claim that we are
forced to hand over our privacy rights
in order to participate in society which
makes at least anecdotal sense
even pre-internet it's understood that
by stepping into the public sphere one
loses any expectation of privacy as they
scream at some poor trader joe's
employee
sure you can get rid of your facebook
profile with a bit of effort but doing
so will cause a drastic increase in the
number of friends
birthdays that you miss and an immediate
and marked decrease in the number of
parties you get invited to
for another example by now we're all
mostly aware that rideshare and other
apps may track us
even when we're not using their services
so how many of us
actually went out of our way to delete
those apps and call an actual cab
every time we want a late night ride
home from the bar and that's not even
touching on how easy it is to manipulate
people out of their personal information
even when they're trying to keep it safe
as carnegie mellon researchers
discovered in their review of behavioral
analysis and experiments on people's
responses to privacy invasion
it is startlingly simple to con people
out of their data
so much so they concluded that to be
effective privacy policy should protect
the naive the uncertain and the
vulnerable
it should be sufficiently flexible to
evolve with the emerging unpredictable
complexities of the information age
so we find ourselves in a bit of a
pickle on the one hand
many of the technologies that make the
modern world possible demand our
personal
information in exchange for access and
most of us have decided to fork it over
on the other hand privacy is critical
for the development of fully formed
individuals what julie cohen calls
situated selves who in their turn are
the starting point for democracy which
most of us at least still claim to want
how society will deal with this
conundrum is still up in the air there's
some resistance to our compulsive data
collecting seen in the european union's
general data protection regulation which
requires companies connected to disclose
many of their data collection practices
and apple's most recent pro-privacy
publicity push
or maybe it's all futile either way the
issue of privacy is one we'll need to
keep talking about
as long as we're still interested in
being people who can gover themselves
what do you think wisecrack what's the
state of privacy in the world today and
where is the debate headed
let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
all your support be sure to hit that
subscribe button and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you